honneur aux enfants ce soir pour ouvrez
votre journal ils étaient 800
aujourd'hui au parc de rouelles pour un
grand rallye environnement autour de
différents ateliers les écoliers ont
découvert la faune et la flore ou comme
ici le cycle de l'eau est aujourd'hui
les bandes a écouté un professeur un peu
particulier en ce moment a fait cuire
fait cuire dans une casserole
on voit l'eau au départ tu as bu tout à
fait de la fumée lotus a fait de leur
mieux c'est ça évaporation comme pierre
40 retraités bénévoles ont accompagné
des enfants captivés ils sont très
demandés respectifs quand tu leur profil
leur parler et je pense que c'est
quelque chose de vraiment essentiel qui
est vraiment rapports
intergénérationnels entre des enfants et
les grands parents
objectif réussi pour cette journée
environnement aboutissement d'un long
travail en classe alors quand il pas
quelque chose un papier qui craignent
qu'on lui fait beaucoup plus offrit blé
du fait pour qu'on les a préparés à cela
aux enfants maintenant de convertir
leurs parents à l'environnement